hi i'm finn whit rock i'm amanda
seifried and this is wired's complete
auto interview
auto complete okay
and auto complete like it's one word out
of it
[Music]
is amanda seyfried married to her dog
a flight attendant that's actually the
question
oh no
okay the answer is no that's what it's
afraid
vegan wait i thought i was just a guess
what was here okay yeah that's fine um
nope not vegan close
here's the mind of seyfried
in twilight
no i really went twice i was in
catherine hardrick's movie after
twilight who's asking um it was a red
riding hood with the great gary oldman
here's a man seifried
a gemini i'm like a
dead center sag
what does that mean it means that i am
exactly what they say i am is that true
that people actually
asked if i could place it that's not
true is it true this is what google
thinks okay whatever is
finn wit rock
nice
i think you're super super nice too it's
too nice maybe there's like a festering
too nice inside of you
is fin mitt rock
british
wrong yeah he found my secret
you have an amazing american accent i
keep in the accent all at all times is
finra rickrock says real name okay time
to come clean my floral name is peter
finn crowley whip rock that's the god's
honest truth peter finn my mom wanted to
name me finn and my dad's name is peter
so why isn't it finn peter
that's a great question is finra
fin rock in the american horror story
the rock is an american horror story
season 10. out now really on a hulu in
this new one i'm uh i'm a normal dad
who is a writer and goes to provincetown
to write and and winds up with a pill
that makes him very inspired to write
but the side effect of the pill is that
you crave human blood
what is amanda psy fred
like in real life difficult
super difficult yeah i have a lot of
opinions
and i just
throw things at people what is amanda
say free doing for fun
what are you doing for fun right now on
thursday or friday when on a tuesday
night i'm usually watching bachelor
paradise but that's over so i guess back
to mondays i'll be watching bachelor i
always imagine you uh like with your
goats
yeah you know i hang out with the
animals and then i
like milking goats no i don't have any i
don't have any you don't have goats i
have goats i don't want any milk
sorry what
inspires amanda
instagram inspires me that's no joke
instagram inspires me i'll take it i
follow a lot of crafters and it's so
inspiring
what oh crap what
song
does amanda say fret what the heck sing
sing in
ted two
mean oh
oh no wait how does it go i don't
remember it mean old moon
uh seth macfarlane wrote it i think i
recorded in a studio before i started
shooting it must be a popular song if
it's being googled
so often what is next for amanda cipher
great answer what's next for what's next
for you well at some point i'm gonna die
um what's next for me i'm going home
awesome great answer
what is finn rit rock
what is so many things stardust
dreams like in real life pretty boring
pretty dull pretty pretty pretty pretty
dull i agree with that
what is
sign scorpio i'm a scorpio because your
birthday's coming up october 28th what
episode is finn bit rock what episode
are you finn episode i'm in the episode
where i
am in this press junket with amanda
seyfried what episode is finn rit rock
in criminal minds i think it's called
true genius
they're like
boy geniuses and then
kill the girl together it's a little bit
you killed somebody in that one i will
work turtleneck that's what i remember
most that's what a boy genius would wear
what is next for finn whit rock gonna go
home make some dinner you're gonna make
it
uh i'm probably going to eat it do you
decide who has dinner it's the same
thing no sorry not who has it
you can't eat tonight do you decide what
you eat like it's the worst question
ever what do you want for dinner yeah i
usually throw things out there and then
i lose the argument what's next for
finland i'm going to do the green
lantern that's what's next does amanda
seyfried
my sister
have a sibling a sister she's great
amanda fred have a youtube channel
not that i know of if i had a youtube
channel my youtube channel would be
goats mostly videos showing people how
to crochet certain things with a bunch
of animals around with a bunch of
animals around i'd watch that
if i had extra time it does amanda
seyfried sing in mamma mia
i sing a lot i sing a lot less than the
second one in fact i had more songs in
the second one and they were given
to someone else
merrell no
no
does amanda's psyche
we're never gonna know i'm doing that
does she
dye her hair oh no but i did just get it
highlighted up here for a roll no i have
never dyed my oh i did do a shampoo once
when i was 19 and it stained my hair
because it was porous and now no i i
this is me
do you work out
yeah sure i work at now and again
do you have tattoos you don't have
touches no no tattoos why i can't commit
to something that i want for the rest of
my life but now that you i would like to
have tattoos i think they're super cool
i just i could never be like that's the
thing yeah i'm the same
does vmware rock have a twin no i don't
have a twin i have a younger brother
named dylan rock he's four years younger
yes he's in the movie he plays
my son in the movie yeah on google you
always confuse me with finn wolfhard who
is could be my son he's so young people
like tagged me in like stranger things
oh he's a stranger things have the guy
and i'm like finn
rock was so good at stranger things like
do you have instagram
yeah instagram just my name look me up
how
to pronounce amanda's how to pronounce
yeah i've had trouble without the e's
you just pretend there's no ease sex
that's what i learned deciphered
sci-fi it doesn't matter doesn't
it seifried it does matter how is
so you're doing it you're doing pretty
good you're good
wait
no i'm pretty good that's really what
they asked how are you good i feel like
i'm fine honestly just hold it on she's
good how
to be like
i've i've been asking this question to
myself for a long time in what way like
how do you just do what you do
you know what's really good
stay away from the mirror
also
unless your doctor tells you to don't
weigh yourself either don't weigh
yourself i i agree don't unless you have
to for your doctor you know right no no
one ever likes what they see
how was amanda discovered i wasn't
discovered i wasn't discovered
i discovered my career
i wasn't modeling when i was a kid
yeah because i live because allentown is
where i grew up and it's very near the
city right and so i was going to new
york and and doing like
rogue ninos and vogue bambini's and
magazines and like limited too
and then i started going on auditions
how is finn how are you i'm all right
i'm doing good thanks for asking thanks
for asking google it's not cool these
are people oh people thanks for asking
people how to be like finn is this true
why are they oh it's hard uh get up in
the morning
large
pot of black coffee same same same same
go hiking griffith park
do the crossword puzzle
happy hour
really you go to happy hour with two
kids
it's the best time really how
was finn whitrock discovered these are
all
discovered mike nichols said that he
discovered me he said he said
don't forget you were in the gutter when
i found you he saw me in a pla it wasn't
really the good i was in a play a tony
kushner play off broadway mike nichols
sounds like that
but you got yourself to where you are
because you worked your ass off
and you're very talented
likewise also you went to
juilliard that's hard yeah i always
thought juilliard was like super snooty
it turns out my best friend went there
yeah and some very close friends daniel
samuel yeah sammy so oh james lau james
oh yeah
yeah he's great how
many movies has infinite rock passed on
i've been
been in i i know you got a imdb me
the last time i counted
nine
you 15 i don't know i really don't know
it's like when someone out in the street
asks you how do i know you where do i
know you from i don't know tell me where
do i know you from somebody did say i i
remember you were joanie on all my
children and i was like yeah
um
no but because she wrote me off i got to
do mean girls so i actually appreciate
her a lot she knew sometimes you're
crying one day and you're hopeless and
then the next day a new opportunity just
falls into your lap
you get to be in mean girls thank you
wired